sur cette bannière qui claquent au vent
en ce dimanche de commémoration le
visage de maurice genevoix marquant
l'entrée du centre culturel qui porte
son nom
écrivain en effet vécu tout près de là
dans ce village de saint denis de
l'hôtel au bord du fleuve loire qui
l'inspira et fit son bonheur mais le
centre culturel maurice genevoix permet
de découvrir aussi l'autre phase de son
histoire et de son génie d'écrivain
l'histoire de ces centaines de milliers
d'hommes happé par la guerre dans
laquelle et se retrouva lieutenant en
1914 dans les tranchées des éparges dont
voici ce qu'il témoigne en tout à fait
nul et maaf des voirons de l'entonnoir
les voix gémissante pleure je plais
après supplie je révolte
je me suis allongé près du commandant
sénéchal et j'ai jeté sur moi que j'ai
ramassé grièvement blessé mais
survivants au massacre soient plus
grande douleur aurait été de survivre à
une génération décimé sa féminité ses
anciens camarades et à verdun était
vraiment très
travis très présent tout le temps il
n'en parlait pas mais je sais que toute
sa vie il a souffert mais ce qui la
déchire et jusqu'à la fin de sa vie
c'était l'amour perdu ses calmes à ses
camarades ses amis amis d'enfance amis
l'école normale car il anticipe et sur
la guerre maurice genevoix loin des
couples et patriotards entonné le plus
souvent très à l'arrière des premières
lignes de front écrivait en 1921
ces lignes la bien peu académique quel
sens
tout ça n'a pas de sens le monde sur la
crête des éparges le monde entier dans
au long du temps une espèce de farce
démentent tournoient autour de moi dans
un très mou cement incompréhensible et
grotesque de cette immense tragédie
il écrivit un chef-d'oeuvre ceux de 14
et l'an prochain pour le centenaire de
l'armistice le musée de la marine de
loire de châteauneuf consacrera une
exposition d'envergure à cet homme dont
la leçon de vie tient toujours
quand on a été dès sa genèse 23 24 ans
as moins 24 ans au contact quotidien de
la mort eh bien on a compris on a
compris vraiment avec sa chère avec ses
viscères que la vie est une chose
merveilleuse et qu'elle le reste
jusqu'au bout
[Musique]